ladies and gentlemen a woman who i find
to be one of the most arresting women
who has ever
lived on this earth and a woman
who's not afraid to be arrested jane
fonda
hello guru i'm so happy to see you
oh god i'm so happy to see you too i
know i'm supposed to be asking you
questions but oh my god i love you so
much
we've known each other for a long time i
mean here i am
sitting in a kind of a basement room
that i fixed up and you're in a studio
you're really doing this serious and i'm
so excited for you
thank you can i show and share a tick
tock that
everybody has already seen and it went
totally viral
um but it's you and quarantine
and i love this video so much
because i think when things get
heavy you try to find the window of
appropriateness to bring in
a sense of humor i mean look at you i i
love you
so much it's just this is so fun
i've been to your house for a party by
the way that was
your parties by the way everybody jane
fonda parties
are epic i remember well you came with
chelsea handler
i did it was a terrible mood
i kind of also like separated and did my
own thing that's the thing
i'm a solo bird you have a full-blown
disco in your house it's
like it's got lights like it looks like
a disco
yeah well that was my ex-lover and a
different house
and i don't do that anymore but see what
that relationship brought you a disco
it brought me a disco and the and and a
few other things
too recently you said um that you're
swearing off men
can i please talk to you about this
because i'm i think i'm there and have
been there for the last five years
why am i here why are you here what's
happening you're so
young you're too young to swear off
anything ever you've got to stay open to
anything drew
i'm uh i'm too old so it it's very easy
to swear off
getting undressed even in candlelight
your argument though was so good you
were talking about your full life
and your friends and your kids and your
philanthropic endeavors and your
work and your life is so full and i
think it's time
yes this is where i've been at now
listen i'm not closed for business but i
have been exactly in that mentality for
the last five years thinking
i just don't have the bandwidth i don't
know if i'm willing to open my i just
don't i just i can't fit it in
well you can squeeze a little a fair or
two in there
i'm all for it i i i love it your whole
life
i loved jane in five acts and
when you're an activist and there are so
many things
going on and so many battles to choose
how do you choose one and have
the courage again to go out there and
get on the bullhorn about it
let me give you a metaphor that may help
you
okay because you and i and so many of
us celebrities think a lot about what is
our role in the crises
you know do we have a right to speak out
because we're attacked a lot when we do
but think of it this way you know those
those antennas that are on the top of
mountains
they're they're antennas that stick up
they're called repeaters
and what they do is they pick up the
voices in the valley
that aren't quite strong enough to make
it up over the mountain
and they lift the voices up to give them
a wider audience so that's what you are
all you are is a repeater so you just
have to be as good a repeater as you can
well time magazine said that your book
would be the most anticipated book
of the fall you were able to put into
words the climate crisis that made it
feel
like there is hope well there is hope i
mean the scientists
who lay out the dire warnings they all
say
but we can do it we have
we have the technology to do it we have
the money to do it
we have everything that we need except
the numbers of people we just need more
people one thing i've always loved and
admired
is a life truly lived and i can't think
of
anyone on this planet who has lived a
more extraordinary life than you
and and i think i'll always
in the presence of greatness feel like
i've never met you
i just stand there and stare at you in
awe
but i do know you a little bit i'm so
happy to know you
you're talking like this is coming to an
end is this over i hope not
i suppose so but i just know this i'm
not going to that death bed without
milking every moment
and seeing everything and telling
everyone how much i love and admire them
because i got to get out of this life
knowing that
i i put my heart out there and you have
had my heart my whole life and and will
continue to do so
this is going to be a huge hit this this
show that you're doing i'm really happy
for you
thank you you're ensuring that by your
presence
because your lifelong credibility is
because of everything that you've done
and accomplished and not talked about
but
action
ladies and gentlemen time magazines the
must-read of 2020. pick your copy up and
find your hope
thank you jane thank you for coming on
the show
thank you so much i love you bye i love
you oh my god okay
we'll be right back
[Music]